[Music]
it's a business opportunity we go door
to door we saw magazines we explore like
America we party come with us
[Music]
Johnny when he was gonna miss you not
really
okay good you're hired
is she okay oh yeah you got key bring
your prayers on I've been trying to be
Christian but I can see the devil has a
hold of the two of you the devil has a
hold of your daughter
do you have any dreams
[Music]
it's like future trips loser Rashmi you
think you're special
you don't mean that
[Music]
scared bank
start with my legs so tell me what was
it that you don't agree with it J does
the lying he ain't lying he's selling
that's his job I don't get what you want
you want to make money or you don't I
want to make money what I want to make
money
she just needs more time I'm good with
the wild ones you know not a [ __ ] cow
it cost me when you don't earn do you
get that this [ __ ] the motel the gas
everything that cost me and I can't run
my business like that do you show me you
can do it or I'll leave you on the side
of the road clear crystal is that a joke
no
[Music]
we have business to take care of
[Music]
you